the Dutton Clan continues to expand in
1923 but their complicated lineage may
send viewers scrambling to remember
who's who we're here to explain the
entire Dutton family tree and all its
connections Margaret and James Dutton
are the first members of the Dutton
family we meet chronologically speaking
as they are the focus of the prequel
series 1883. while the two aren't main
characters in the Yellowstone spin-off
1923 their absence casts a long Shadow
what they left behind forms the basis
for what unfolds Margaret and James
kick-started the Dutton family as they
set out from their home in Tennessee for
a new life in Oregon well I just say
that I just want you to know it now I'm
nervous after joining an ill-fated wagon
train across the frontier death and
disaster forced them to stake their
claim in Paradise Valley Montana the
premiere episode of 1923 however
confirms that James died 10 years after
arriving in Montana as seen briefly in a
Yellowstone flashback following his
passing Margaret made a desperate plea
to her husband's brother Jacob to come
lead the family on the Dutton Ranch in
the premiere of 1923 it's revealed that
when he arrived a year later he
discovered Margaret frozen to death in a
snow drift 1883 doesn't avoid the fact
that not every death in the wild west
was Grand or Noble
the central character of 1883 Elsa was
the first son to die on the frontier she
was killed by an infection brought on by
a Lakota Arrow received in a battle
during their trip to Oregon it was
Elsa's death that forced the Dutton Clan
to stop and make their home in Montana
but her presence is felt from beyond the
grave as the narrator of 1923. in the
series premiere Elsa delivers a warning
about what's to come revealing that only
one of her parents children will live to
see his children grow only one would
carry the fate of this family through
the depression
and every other hail the 20th century
heralded them she claims that the family
Empire will crumble under her uncle
Jacob's watch though she lost her life
before the Yellowstone Dutton Ranch was
even founded Elsa remains a forceful
presence her gravestone can still be
seen in current episodes of Yellowstone
and it would seem that she still has a
part to play in the events of 1923 as
well
Jacob Dutton owns the Yellowstone gun
wrench which has become a genuine Empire
Jacob is the brother of 1883 star James
Dunton he arrived in the region after
James's death in 1893. this also makes
him the brother of Claire Dunton who
took her own life after the death of her
daughter at the beginning of 1883. in
1923 Jacob is the adoptive father to
James's surviving children John and
Spencer he serves as Montana's livestock
commissioner the same role that will one
day be held by his descendants John
Dutton III and Casey Dutton many decades
later on Yellowstone this suggests that
the family has controlled the government
position since Montana's founding but
Jacob has made enemies among rival
landowners who resent the large area of
Montana that his family calls home your
enemies are going to be so terrified
that their fear
is greater than their greed this becomes
particularly problematic when the region
is ravaged by both drought and locusts
with 1923 setting the stage for a range
War Jacob will have to be just as Fierce
as James before him if he's to protect
the family Legacy
Cara Dutton Jacob's wife and the family
matriarch arrived on the Yellowstone
Dutton ranch with her husband in 1894.
on her Landing in Montana she took in
James and Margaret's children John and
Spencer and raised them as her own the
close bond between Kara and her nephews
is evident from the very beginning as
her emotional letter to Spencer makes
clear she's just as close to her
grandson Jack son of John the first
showcased in the series premiere as she
helps him smooth over an incident with
his fiancee Elizabeth she makes it clear
to Elizabeth that being a Rancher's wife
is a tough job and you will be free
Cara is a kind and gentle family leader
but she's as Fierce and deadly as any
done when her family is threatened
Carrick and Tangle with the best of them
and is not to be underestimated
rather than revolving around Jacob
Dutton many Yellowstone fans may have
assumed that 1923 would focus on the now
middle-aged Dutton son John a forebearer
of Kevin Costner's John Dunn III John
the son of James and Margaret Dutton was
just a child when we met him in 1883. by
the opening of 1923 he's in his mid-40s
and married to Emma Dunn with a grown
son of his own named Jack John is his
uncle's right-hand man in his job as
livestock commissioner and appears to
play a big role in running the
Yellowstone Dutton Ranch however we know
from Elsa's voiceover that only one of
James Dunn's children will survive the
20th century will it be John or is he
destined to die in 1923
in Yellowstone Beth dutton's role on the
ranch is largely administrative but in
1923 women are integral to the
day-to-day operations of the property
that means that Emma Dutton the wife of
John Dunn the first has a key part to
play in running the wrench Emma is not
only John's wife but also a caretaker of
the ranch when the Cowboys are away she
tends to the horses and keeps the
grounds in the absence of John Jacob and
the others on the early 20th century
Yellowstone the women are often left to
take care of the ranch on their own as
caring for the herd keeps the ranch
hands gone for days weeks or even months
at a time
we first meet James son Spencer Dutton
in Yellowstone in a flashback set in the
year 1893. he wasn't born during the
events of 1883 when the duttons were
making their way across the Plains and
when 1923 begins he isn't living on the
Dutton Ranch as the series starts we
learned that Spencer Dutton is a veteran
of the Great War what we now call World
War one and is haunted by his
experiences in combat since that time
Spencer has been working in Africa as a
big game hunter hired to rid tourist
locales of wild animals like lions and
leopards his aunt Cara who raised him
after the death of his mother still
misses him as she writes to him across
the world wondering if his absence is
some form of punishment we're not quite
sure where Spencer's story in 1923 will
take him but there's a fair chance he
won't stay away from the ranch forever
we haven't heard much about this dun
member before but that doesn't stop him
from having a lead role in 1923. Jack
Dutton is the son of John and Emma
Dunton and in the Premier episode is
engaged to be married why do I have to
wait a week why can't the cattle wait a
week raised by his parents on the Dutton
Ranch he maintains a close relationship
with his Grand Aunt Cara and is a
capable Cowboy himself though
unconfirmed so far in 1923 it's at least
possible that Jack is actually a younger
version of John Dutton senior the
elderly ancestor we've met in
Yellowstone flashbacks as the father of
Kevin Costner's John Dunton John Dutton
senior appeared in a touching scene Atop
A Mountain as he said goodbye to the
Yellowstone don't let him take it away
from the Sun
not a god damage in that scene it's
noted that John Senior is in his 90s
which would put his birth date around
the turn of the 20th century lining up
neatly with Jack's age on the other hand
Costner's John Dunn III notes that he's
the sixth generation montanan meaning
that Jack is actually his grandfather
only time will tell
in the first episode of 1923 Elizabeth
Stratford is set to become the newest
member of the Dutton family her father
is a friend of Dutton patriarch Jacob
and she's engaged to be married to
Jacob's Grand nephew Jack the ceremony
is postponed when Jack needs to join a
cattle drive that's when Elizabeth
really gets that being a Rancher's wife
will be no picnic if Elizabeth is the
soon-to-be wife of the young Cowboy Jack
Dunn that may make her the mother or
grandmother of Kevin Costner's John
Dutton III on Yellowstone there's still
plenty of story left to be told in 1923
but we fully expect the series to tie up
the Dutton family tree with the story of
Elizabeth and Jack's marriage
we're still not 100 certain how the rest
of the Dutton family tree comes together
but it won't be much past 1923 for us to
start seeing some familiar faces whether
the Young Jack Dutton is the same older
man we've already met on Yellowstone or
whether he's his father or someone else
entirely it's clear that those family
figures aren't far away they may even
pop up at some point over the course of
1923's two seasons but there are other
options as Creator Tyler Sheridan could
introduce a new family Branch we haven't
seen coming regardless of how he's
related to the characters in 1923 we
know John Dutton will manage the
Yellowstone Dutton Ranch through the
latter half of the 20th century
you know the first stud is to settle
this Valley fighting was all they knew
that's how they got here how they kept
the land once they did
at some point in the 1950s John Doug II
will sire his namesake John Dunton III
and in the late 80s or early 90s he'll
pass ownership of the ranch to John III
as seen in Yellowstone season two that's
life
I swear
the next generation of duttons on the
family tree is perhaps the most diverse
group in the legacy of the Yellowstone
dun Ranch in the premiere episode of
Yellowstone John Dutton III's eldest son
Lee is killed leaving Casey and Jaime as
the only male heirs Casey was an outcast
at the time living with his native
American wife Monica on the broken rock
reservation it's later revealed that
Jamie Dutton was adopted whether his
father John will view Jaime as a true
member of the family Still Remains to be
seen on the other side of things John
III's daughter Beth is a ruthless
corporate Raider and seems far less
interested in the family's Fortune where
the ranch is concerned she's also unable
to Bear her own children she has married
Yellowstone's enforcer rip wheeler a
tough as Nails cowboy who essentially
runs the wrench I Believe In Loving with
your whole soul
and destroying anything
that wants to kill what you love when
the time comes for John Dutton III to
hand over the Yellowstone Ranch to his
heirs it'll be interesting to see to
whom he'll leave it Casey his son by
Blood Jamie is Son by choice or his
daughter Beth and son-in-law rip wheeler
of course that assumes the ranch is
still standing when all is said and done
Yellowstone could culminate with the end
of the Legacy we're witnessing in 1923.
I saw a universe
Beyond Casey Jamie and Beth lies another
generation of dungeons who are just
children now first and foremost among
them is Tate done the now teenage son of
Casey and Monica as it stands Tate is
the only one of his generation to be
related by blood that can be traced back
through John Dunn the first in 1923 all
the way to James and Margaret Dutton of
1883. you're gonna grow up and I'm gonna
go
Tate does have a familial cousin Beyond
blood however Jaime's Son by his former
assistant Christina Wesley Dunn Jr
continues to carry the family name more
distant is Carter young boy taken in by
Beth Dutton and her husband rip wheeler
but this generation of duttons by blood
or otherwise could spell Doom for the
family and their legacy when James
Dutton first settled in Paradise Valley
it was said that and in seven
generations
my people will rise up and take it back
from you
Jack Dunn is the grandfather of John
Dutton III then Tate and his generation
could signal the end of the Yellowstone
Dutton wrench
[Music]